ni el partido conservador ni el Primer
Ministro Richie sunak han logrado
cumplir con la promesa de reducir la
emigración al Reino Unido pese ha sido
una de sus banderas de campaña para
ganar elecciones en la última década y
especialmente con el brexit la oficina
Nacional de estadísticas reveló que la
inmigración neta al Reino Unido en el
2022 superó los
660.000 personas estos significaba Un
aumento importante con el récord
anterior de medio millón este aumento se
explica por la entregada de visas a más
de un millón doscientos mil personas
fuera de la Unión Europea que vinieron
aquí al Reino Unido a trabajar o a
estudiar o también personas que han
estado o hicieron parte de un conflicto
y esto también significa el programa
especial que creó el gobierno para que
los ucranianos pudieran llegar a este
país la situación Por supuesto es muy
compleja para el Primer Ministro Richie
sunak porque está contra las cuerdas su
partido el conservador que quiere que la
inmigración al Reino Unido sea lo más
baja posible y por ello el premiere ha
dicho hoy que la situación y esta cifra
es demasiado alta Así que podemos
esperar nuevas medidas como las que
anunció esta semana del gobierno Y es
que los estudiantes de posgrado que
vengan al Reino Unido ya no podrán traer
a sus familias a que vivan con ellos
mientras cursan estos estudios y que
también se evitará que los estudiantes
de posgrado puedan cambiar sus visas de
estudiantes a visas de trabajo esto
mientras el gobierno continúa con la
Batalla de los tribunales para lograr
que pueda enviar a los inmigrantes
ilegales que llegan a través del Canal
de la Mancha a Ruanda PC a todas las
críticas y advertencias de que este es
un programa cruel e inhumano